six months ago Alisha Cowie was crowned
missing happy and healthy now but as a
teenager she says she was dragged into a
dark place by Instagram searching for
fitness advice she found herself in a
community that encouraged anorexia and
self-harm I would self-harm on my arms
my legs and this was suggested to you on
insta
it was a port that I've seen on
Instagram before that I had no idea what
- something you would not have thought
of doing no definitely not I didn't have
any idea of what it was I was only 13
and never come across suicide or
self-harm and this just pops up on your
timeline yeah from the post that I was
suggested from the way at loss it had a
hashtag which was for anorexic people to
post pictures of how they're feeling and
from that there was self-harm and
pictures under this anorexic hashtag so
those two things seemed to be almost
aged thirteen Alicia should have been
putting on weight but in the course of a
year lost three stone eventually a
friend's suicide shocked her out of her
downward spiral does like destroy lives
and it ends life sometimes so it's it
needs to be kind of figured out in 2017
Molly Russell took her own life after
viewing self-harm and suicide material
on Instagram a high profile campaign by
her family forced the social media
company to make a statement last month
that our aim is to have no graphic
self-harm or graphic suicide related
content on Instagram so we set up an
account to test whether they'd kept
their promise it took very little time
to find that they hadn't we're not going
to show you any of these images because
they are far too distressing and nor
will we explain how we access them but
they show in graphic detail methods of
self-harm and of suicide it is not only
glamorized but also instructional it is
the exact thing that Instagram said it
would get rid of over a month ago but
it's far too easily accessible without
any filters or warnings
there are some searches on Instagram
that prompt a filter page offering
constructive help would link through to
groups such as the Samaritans but images
are messages that glamorize excessive
weight loss are still too easy to find
at Latimer high school in West London
teachers are worried parents have said
to me that part of the battle when when
trying to help with their child's
recovery is the easy access that they
have to these communities of people who
are essentially undoing all the good
work that the hospital and the parents
are trying to do in a statement
Instagram said we do not and have never
allowed content that encourages or
promotes suicide or self-injury which
includes eating disorders and will
remove it as soon as we made aware of it
as a result of the ongoing expert review
into our approach to all suicide and
self-injury content we no longer allow
any graphic images of self-harm the
company has now removed the self-harm
images we identified to them and told
Sky News it's expecting to make
adjustments to its policy around eating
disorders and is consulting experts on
how to get it right
Jason Farrell Sky News